let's see her I'll be a female please is
Jesus everyone how's it going bros to
avoid any form of cultural appropriation
i will be as white as possible so our
audio options are jacksepticeye
markiplier and pitty pay cut me down
blond white hair I can choose my own
hair and games Oh finally I can
associate with another character whoa
body features breast size you know it's
a good game if there's a breast size
slider and nothing else I mean what else
would you really want to customize
unless thick oh here we are in the
middle of the desert and we got badass I
don't know what you do in this game this
so this is another one of those survival
games I mean we started off the game as
Jesus so we can't be doing too bad
hopefully there's something to kill soon
oh it's a giant oh my god I just
remember I forgot my groceries oh look
there's a guy here ah I like how my tits
are there if I stare down oh I got stone
and [ __ ]
I'm fibers oh god it's one of those
games so far the best game the best part
of this game has been the boobs I'm not
gonna lie look at them holy [ __ ] okay we
have that now what does that mean we can
cook whoa look at that boy what is this
- I'm sorry Stone does this mean
anything I have a feeling I'm not doing
anything you're punching a stone woman I
could just do this all day this is so
fun great everyone how about this one
[ __ ] do I use this for then all right
how do I get water then I don't get
water in a [ __ ] desert build a well
maybe
you were killed by thirst for that ass
there's one of those [ __ ] gargoyle
things again hey listen here buddy
you're not Batman you're not you're just
not hey is this an oasis okay well this
is a lot more [ __ ] Pleasant oh god
there's animals where's the water any
water where there's other humans what
the [ __ ] are they okay never mind I'm
not I won't go down I'm not gonna lose
out on this [ __ ] beautiful they're
behind me anything
god damn say me Chad Oh save me Cato
[ __ ] do something total water perfect
oh my god look it's jacksepticeye water
the essence of laughs oh my god what a
nice form of swimming oh my god you're
so cute oh hey look eggs take them my
eggs mother bye guys you have to cook
these oh my god it's a [ __ ] alligator
[Music]
goddamn alligator
get a [ __ ] out of me alligators can't
swim haha what just happened what just
happened what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
just happened what the you can't just
you can't just do that for [ __ ] sake
hey how about that all my progress lost
my favorite game hey it's a buddy kill
it
[ __ ] you bunny come here bunny came
right I need food honey all right now we
need to defend ourselves that's right
[ __ ] alligator you're back
damn this game is stressing the hell out
of me I swear to God I just killed it
funny
[ __ ] you bunny oh I'm sorry I didn't
know who's your friend [ __ ]
I'm crippled now it's a fight to the
death twice into them please die please
die please die please die oh how the
[ __ ] did that get up there how what are
you doing up there you got a ladder
stuck up hairball hop my parapa I will
reward you greatly all right where
should we build a bed on a knife safe
location wait that looks [ __ ] awesome
look at that bridge let's go there oh no
that's funny
come on bunny come on bunny aah stop
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me I'm tired of it
I'm tired of you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] oh my god
[Music]
scum
oh my god there's bunny again this is my
chance come on bunny come on bunny bunny
bunny Oh why'd you do that
hey look it'sa me damn that ass doe [ __ ]
run just run Felix
oh my [ __ ] lord oh my god oh oh no oh
you've done it now you oh you don't
oh you've done oh oh now let's build
this [ __ ] bed once and for
mother [ __ ] home now we have a spawn
point thank god oh my god that you piece
o [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] no no I'm not gonna die today
oh my yeah I get it I'm dead [ __ ] me she
says [ __ ] christ
I swear to God if an oh my I hate you
you [ __ ] suck hell yeah I got a
[ __ ] shield voice hell yeah I'm the
king of the nature the danger okay
where's my [ __ ] sword look at that
boy still in our pants but don't worry
about I'll get pants I'll get pants I'm
coming for a revenge
I'm [ __ ] ready boys I'm smoking ready
to kill anything in my sad ready never
been this ready money left my laugh
oh my god on second thought I think not
let's start with this [ __ ] here
this jacksepticeye looking from on the
[ __ ]
he's got France hey that's right that's
right what you gonna do what you gonna
do what you gonna do evil dog Oh evil
daughter [ __ ] you
bring it that's right I'm the king of
the jail jesus H Christ what is
happening are they talking to each other
tarik shut the [ __ ] off
oh my god they're fast now [ __ ]
crippled I'm [ __ ] crippled
too much means lying in the water did it
it's really fun to play a reskin it's
really good game this why do you know
what tell me this is how they used to do
it in the medieval ages just swing away
son
alright here we go where's my [ __ ]
door
did I craft the ceiling I guess I did
yes I did there's Mike that's fair use
this it's the best goddamn house they
feels just like mine crap now I'm
protected from creepers at night
does it get nighttime in this game yes
my house my house what the [ __ ] are you
doing doesn't even give a [ __ ]
smack that ass boy Tama I know yeah now
you wanna know all right then
good bye never mind I am here now die
son of Satan oh you know why you're
doing this what the [ __ ] is
just up just stop your was in these
survival games you always get to this
one point where it's like well I know
how to handle all my stamina bars I've
gotten literally everything now I guess
I can do something else I think I got it
I think I got
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] where's my bed where's my bed
where's my bed where's my [ __ ] back
well I hope you enjoyed another gameplay
it's been a while since we did one let
me know if you want to continue this
series and leave a like if you do and as
always stay awesome brows